David Carr you can see David the network
and NFL Network analysts tonight on NFL
Total Access at 7 p.m. Eastern how
surprised were you what happened the
Rams at home there David it's pretty
surprising defensively they they're not
as strong as they were last year
obviously I think that Bruce Arians has
done a good job with Jameis in his
little shaky at the beginning but you
know last year they led the league in
passing and so they had the they had the
ability to go out there and continue to
do that he's just he's just found a nice
little mixture with that defense I mean
Todd Bowles did a fantastic job Shaq
Barrett is got nine sacks so they made
it tough on Jared Goff I wrote an
article on nfl.com a couple weeks ago
about about kind of Jared Goff and his
struggles just seeing seeing defense
it's still a young quarterback and
they've really relied on the play-action
pass game and the run game of Todd
Gurley and he kind of moved the pocket
to make big plays they tend to get in a
situation where they have to drop back
and throw the football
you know they've struggled a little bit
and it's kind of been that system as
well you go back to Connell Shanahan
Mike Shanahan
they've always been good in the run and
the misdirection play action but as soon
as they get into a drop back pass game
it they kind of struggle a little bit
that's kind of in the same case he's
over 500 yards but he's still Jerry
didn't look sharp so gonna give a little
credit at defense as well yeah I think
as they move forward with if you don't
have the play-action and you know this
better than anybody as a former
quarterback that ability to have
play-action well that makes that
quarterback so much better and I I would
be concerned with the Rams if you're not
really worried about Todd Gurley the way
you once were then all of a sudden it's
Jared Goff as a pocket passer right
exactly and you know there's a Gary
Kubiak
who's now in Minnesota the same office
has been around forever and so I'm
having a conversation with him at one
point and he really believes it's almost
the philosophy of that coaching tree is
that you can only get big plays in the
passing game by extending the pocket and
moving and kind of creating just huge
open spaces for these guys to run free
out of these tight formations and that's
what they've done and as soon as they go
to just the drop back pass a man they
try and keep up with teams here like
Tampa Bay or whatnot get in that mode
they're just not as good and Jared Goff
I remember when he came out at all
our Jeff Fisher told me he was on the
medical network one day he said the only
thing Jared Goff knows about the other
defense that they're wearing a different
colored Jersey so there was like a
there's a big learning curve for him to
understand what he's seeing
recognizing the defense and then making
appropriate drone he still struggles in
that area that's not to say he's not a
great quarterback he is excellent what
Sean McVeigh asked him to do with the
play action game and he's very accurate
in that mode but it's like you said if
you don't have that element of talk
Gurley is not what he was maybe last
year then the threat really isn't there
and then you almost feel like you have
to kind of keep up with teams in a
different way and try and create often
it's another way and it just hasn't been
that's not there
that's not where they're best explain
what happened to the Cowboys offense
last night a face of good defense I mean
obviously the first couple games they
played this year against teams that
struggled a little bit offensively when
you have Zeke out there and he's healthy
and he's not cracking off the 10 12 15
yard runs and that's what they've done
really with that offensive line they
just leaned on that now Kyle he's done a
good job coming in and kind of changed
in that offense up and you know making
it making it more quarterback friendly
given dak answers with pre-snap
alignments and shifts and motions he's
done a good job I applaud him for that
but New Orleans a good football team
especially on the defensive side and
when you're forced to make plays on the
outside like Marshawn Lattimore he plays
great against you know against top level
guys sometimes we we get on him a little
bit about getting beat you know by just
average guys out there but when it's a
top guy when it's Amari Cooper I mean he
steps up and he played he played well
the other night and they put him in a
lot of man coverage situation so they
really challenged dak and the Cowboys to
make throws on the outside now he made a
couple but he didn't make enough to to
really kind of push them over the edge I
mean New Orleans is a good defense I
think that's what we're going to find
out later on as we go as soon as they
get drew back they're going to be there
at the end so if they played a good
football team and they just go up short
any concerns about signing dak Prescott
to that long-term contract yes I think
so I mean but at the same time he's
their franchise quarterback and I've
said this when this topic comes up you
know everyone's looking for that guy and
they have a guy in Dallas now is he
homes no I mean but who is you know so
you have your guy that is effective in
your system you played a good defense
stand up for the first couple weeks he
did what he's supposed to do against you
know average or below average defenses
and then chop them up and go out there
he's just gonna have to really find a
way to make some plays when it counts
and for the most part I mean even last
night he went down there he drove down
the field hit a nice sort of Randall
Cobb I mean they had a chance I thought
New Orleans was brilliant what they did
on the helm here I wish more teams would
do that in that he'll marry situation
some guys just let the quarterback sit
back there for you know five or six
seconds let your guys do down the field
they they pressured him off the edge and
I thought it was brilliant got a hit on
him you know by you know Dax
he's been he's been pretty clutch in
those situations honestly if we're we're
really looking at it since about 2016
he's got the most fourth-quarter
comebacks of any any quarterback in the
league so he plays well in those
situations I think that I think that I
would feel comfortable how was the
Cowboys saying he's my franchise
floormat going forward we just know what
it is I mean that's the going rate is
just he's gonna be the highest-paid
guide I don't know if I necessarily
agree with that but it's the nature of
the position that that's what they're
doing right now can you cover the
Raiders objectively no absolutely not
every day but I mean let's just be real
I mean I'm gonna they ask me okay Dave
we've got got to give out game balls you
know tonight on the show
Josh Jacobs just you I mean he's the
best player I saw on Sunday they're a
good touch Jake if he had like 70 or 80
doesn't matter he's fantastic it ran the
football he closed the game out he
caught the ball well we only had two
catches David doesn't matter give to
Josh Jenkins I try man but it's it's a
it's depressing for me when they lose on
site on on Mondays I go into work and
people are like okay we got to get
Dave's energy level up like he's
depressed you know so it's very nice
when they win a football game against
the Colts
even though they were out without CY
Hilton you know without a lot of their
guys so it was a good win can you be
objective with your brother after a game
if he said how do you think I play yes
yeah absolutely
that's uh I can I can absolutely do that
a lot of times that stuff doesn't make
TV or radio but I enjoy my conversations
with Derek after games he called me last
night and I talked to him on his way to
London and just talked openly about the
game I thought you did a great job
honestly there were some opportunities
that I think both both him and Gruden
would have liked to have back last week
against Minnesota with some shots down
the field and they protected well
yesterday against the Colts and he was
able to take some of those throws made a
nice throw on the touchdown to foster
threw the ball well down the field of
Tyrell Williams and a situation where
maybe he doesn't throw that one up last
you know last week but he's trusted his
guys and they protected well enough it's
where he could make some of those throws
so he's he's accurate down the field I
mean he does a good job I think that you
know the conversation I had last year
with John it was after I think was I got
week eight or nine we were up there for
a game and he came up after the after
the game was talking to the family and I
just started having conversation with me
and Derick really off to the side
because like I got a really trust your
brother's arm a little bit more you know
I think that's been kind of a work in
progress that John is the nature of his
offenses completions high completion
percentage hey loves Derek because
you'll complete 70% as fast like if you
tell Derek we want completions he's
gonna get you three out of four he's
gonna hit him but there's there's the
element of I think that where Derek
really shines and he has Anna his whole
life he's been able to push the ball
down the field of accuracy and if they
don't really make that something that
they focus on and he's not gonna do it
he's gonna find the completion but I
thought about yesterday did a good job
of consciously you know forcing some
shots down the field and his guys made
some plays so it has got to continue to
build on that and I think that'll give
you a chance talking to David Carr NFL
Network analyst you can see him tonight
NFL total accents at 7 p.m. Eastern if
Nick Foles was healthy right now finish
that sentence he'd be it'd be on the
sidelines healthy and watching Gardner
Minshew throw the football around
could you imagine now I know that you
know we get caught up in how much money
somebody makes but you don't feel I mean
it's just like gardeners the guy really
III think that he's he's just a guy that
he's inspired confidence and hope and a
team even though Jalen Ramsey all that
nonsense is going on I mean they still
won out in Denver and found a way to get
a win I mean that's fantastic me he's a
we're in a situation like that you don't
have a great football team a guy
quarterback that gives you hope and can
run around and buy
I'm and make planes like you did on
touchdown throw late-night game I mean
the polls are going to do that
Nick bolts are going and he'll play good
football for you but I mean right now
this is what they need this Gardner is
the best thing they can have going for
with all the nonsense with Jo Anne
Ramsey and we were their team is so I
think I think Nick would be would be
watching Gardner play football it's just
and I if he's healthy he comes back I
think he's still boxing I don't know
what they do next year because I don't I
don't feel like minsu is a guy like
sometimes you get guys and obviously
Baker is kind of in this role a little
bit Baker I'll grow some balls into
coverage and you're kind of kind of
question like why do you why'd you make
that throw it I understand you're giving
your guy a chance
but what Minshew does is he makes those
above the X's and O's plays but then he
doesn't really make the negative plays
he doesn't put your team in bad
situations and I think that you know
behind the moustache and uncle Rico
persona like he's a smart football
player when you watch him on film he
understands exactly what he's seeing
from the defense and at a young age like
this I mean that's that's really
impressive to me so I think he's there
for the long haul honestly and doesn't
never have to have a decision in the
offseason so it's it's fun to watch him
because he looks like he's a kind of a
loose cannon but in reality he knows
what he's doing it's on watch David
great to catch up with you as always we
appreciate your time thanks for joining
us you but that's David Carr and if I'll
Network analysts you can see him tonight
NFL Total Access at 7 p.m. Eastern
Thursday Night Football rams Seahawks on
Fox NFL Network and Amazon Prime video
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]